vous vous étiez présenté au premier tour
vous avez fini par appeler à voter pour
jean marie rolland qui a perdu ce soir
face à jean yves caullet quelle
conclusion vous tirer de ces élections
dans la 2e circonscription de l'yonne
alors effectivement je m'étais présenté
au premier tour comme vous avez pu le
constater c'était pour moi une primaire
est ce que je constate aujourd'hui c'est
que bien entendu jean yves caullet est
arrivé avec une courte courte avance sur
jean marie rolland ce que je constate
c'est que ma candidature en fait n'a pas
desservis jean marie rolland bien au
contraire puisque si l'on mesure les
voix que j'ai obtenu au premier tour
celles ci se sont reportés sur
jean-marie
et notamment à chablis puisque chablis
fait à peu près 60 2% jean marie rolland
fait à peu près 62% des voix
ce que je remarque aussi c'est que si on
additionne toutes les voies de la
famille de la droite au premier tour
jean marie rolland avait emmagasiné 39%
des voix et
malheureusement on peut constater que
les voix qui sont allées en direction du
front national au premier tour et bien
apparemment et ne se sont pas aucune ou
très peu se sont reportés sur les voix
de jean marie rolland